i want to pull up this story uh this is
from the daily wire majority of
democrats back trudeau's crackdown
freezing bank account of truckers
there's something really important here
ian was just saying that he doesn't
think donald trump could win the
presidency because they're going to be
ready for them right yeah so uh
using the same strategy twice the
previous context for those that may have
missed it we're talking about the
freedom convoy in canada we're talking
about how trudeau cracks down then the
u.s is playing this convoy and ian you
are saying that they're going to be
ready for the u.s truckers
so they can't use the same strategy
they're going to be ready for donald
trump he can't use the same strategy but
there's one thing that i think does that
you may overlook in this in this regard
what if
instead of you know a thousand or 500
trucks coming to dc like in canada it
was 50 000.
now it was reported there was 50 000
truckers protesting i don't think there
was that many trucks i think that was
probably misreported but let's say that
dc does plan for this and they say
we're going to handle it
500 trucks no problem but then 50 000
trucks from every angle come in you
can't handle that there's no planning
for that that would be a different uh a
different plan so let me show you this
in the story about democrat support for
trudeau they say
the the poll shows 55 percent of general
election voters disapprove of trudeau's
handling of the protesters 35 percent
approved that is to say the majority of
people don't like the the draconian
powers take a look at this
democrats 65 percent approval
republicans 87
disapproval and independence 74
disapproval that is to say
republicans saying no to trudeau
unaffiliated voters say no to to trudeau
it is only the democrat base that about
two-thirds support what trudeau is doing
with these draconian powers
this this these metrics are reflected in
basically everything when we pull up
civics polling data is the economy good
independent voters two to one say no
republicans
ten to one say no
democrats two to one say it's great
now how is that possible it's an
inversion the fact is
independent voters and republicans the
plurality of the majority of people in
this country do not live in the crackpot
cult reality that the democrats live in
so if donald trump does run again they
can plan any shadow campaign or whatever
fortification they want but when 10
times many people are storming to the
gates no amount of planning will stop
that man yeah the independence there is
really important because that's your
proxy right i mean those are the people
that aren't really affiliated i mean if
if they're siding with republicans i
mean not even siding with them but if
that's the way they're perceiving
reality right but you're but this is all
these represent the chasm right the
chasm that we're talking about it's we
kind of forked at a certain point
culturally in this country and the chasm
is just so great you might try to holler
at somebody way over there it's just
like what's the point i mean they're not
even going to understand the language
that i'm speaking right now
you know that's scary but but to your
point like
i don't know how we're going to remedy
that cultural problem that we're
experiencing the chasm's just too wide i
think that that's that's making me think
of that mentality that combat mentality
versus the scientific mentality and so
many people are in combat mentality that
if you try and speak to them
scientifically with like facts and
evidence they don't get it it's too big
of a deal for them to think about they
got to act now this is it's like life or
death to these people so if you can
understand that before you start
communicating with them and
for them it's a big deal maybe for you
it's not i mean obviously i'm not
freaked out by this stuff but
if you understand there it's same with
saying talking with a kid too if you
understand why something's such a big
deal to them it's a lot easier to
communicate with them about it
yeah rapport building is is the first
strategy in in persuasion yes so if you
approach someone as an enemy or as an
other
they are less likely to trust you they
fear you
so if you're trying to actively build
bridges in the political conflict you
have to approach
your political enemies or your political
rivals
as one of them
it's a very difficult thing to do
i i i gotta throw it to uh daryl davis
though and say i think we're beyond that
unfortunately you can certainly try i'm
not saying never you know give up but
that story about daryl davis he's the
guy who who de-radicalized those claims
the black jazz musician de-radicalizes
clan members but when he tried to talk
with antifa outside of the event we
booked him for they wouldn't talk to him
yeah he directly confronted the mob and
that's that's a hard that's a big ask
i've never successfully confronted a mob
and come out at the winner but confront
maybe is the wrong word he just said
addressed themselves i want to talk to
them yeah he walked across the street
and they started yelling at him and they
called him a nazi and other you know
white supremacists and he was like just
want to talk guys and they wouldn't do
it something similar might have happened
though if he was trying to address like
a clan rally no he's done that he's done
but but it started at the individual
level right it was just like one guy and
then another showed up to clan rallies
he went to clan rallies and walked up to
people and talked to them
and he posted about how
never he never experienced what he did
with antifa when he when when he went to
clan rallies they were like what's this
guy doing here and he said you know he
started talking to people and they
started talking with him and they told
him all of their racist ideas and he
said okay
just wondering what you were thinking
and then after a long enough period of
time they realized they were wrong
and their racist ideas weren't correct
with antifa he walks up and they scream
at him they won't even let him talk yeah
they want to fight they're there to
fight so it's a more poisonous ideology
than racism even
oh i certainly think so
i think the issue with racism is that
it's it's it's
incorrect and can lead people towards
dangerous policy and violence
the far-left extremism is inherently on
on step one of the hopscotch is be
extreme and destroy racism is you you
don't like people for stupid reasons it
escalates from there antifun the far
left starts with violent revolution i
hate that burn it all down mental it's
so stupid like it yeah why would you
ever destroy what we've created before
you have a new thing to do what the
it's a 12 year old mentality yeah it's
so very short-sighted immature right so
it's extremely immature yeah and it's
extremely
you know short-sighted and
so now
you know like i said no one's gonna make
me feel guilty for being born i wouldn't
have chose
my parents love them um take take a take
a bunch of 10 year olds take 30 10 year
olds and put them in charge of an office
building see what happens
this is this is what's happening right
now good times make weak men we're in
the fourth turning we're in the period
of weak men who have made hard times
although i'm thinking now figuratively
because women are involved i'm thinking
scorched earth now because that's a
military tactic so if these people
really are in combat mind state
then the scorched earth tactic is on the
table like if someone's invading your
city and you can't defend it properly
you burn the entire city to the ground
and retreat so that when they get there
they don't have a city to pillage and so
maybe that's what these people are doing
i think you know what you see is even
that thought through that far
there there is um
it's a rudimentary
plan it's there
anti-fun portland
they
everything they do
serves their purpose their goal right
if they go out in the streets with guns
and say do as you're told and you do
they win
if you resist them and there's chaos and
fighting you're destroying the system
they win
it's what they want from the ashes of
the old they shall build anew it's what
they said during occupy wall street
i was told during occupy they said the
organizer said we want to flip the
pyramid over
and i said
how would that make sense
if you flip the pyramid over you have
one brick on the bottom no
the pyramid crumbles and forms a crappy
or crumbly pyramid and they're like
right and we're on the bottom now and
when you flip it over and the bricks
tumble down we'll be the ones on top
that was their view their view was not
to create a better world where the
working class were all equal and wealthy
it was that if you flip the pyramid over
some of the poor people will take
control and be in charge the rest is
going to fall down the side of the
pyramid the avalanche of rocks and get
crushed that's right we're definitely in
payback mode right this is
payback for what for who the federal
reserve the idea of how they've been
wronged and why
we are
so systematically
racist and this and that fascist yes and
so
when you if you're in payback mode
then you're not being rational and
you'll get these type of ideas and it
seems so fulfilling it again but it's so
emotionally based yeah people that are
willing to die for their cause are very
dangerous yes but these people also have
no sense of history they don't know what
happened in cuba or either that or
they're ignorant about it i was just so
funny i was just listening the other day
to an interview with andy garcia the
actor and i had no idea he was from cuba
and his family fled from there when he
was five and a half years old and the
interviewers asked him is just like so
what was that like you fled from cuba i
mean what was going on and the way that
he describes cuba that he fled from is
just like hair raising he was just like
well you know the we we were told we're
gonna be public schools and the
revolution was gonna bring everybody
happiness and the public schools weren't
really schools they were just
indoctrination camps and all the
children you know there was no god and
they praised che guevara and they
praised fidel and he's just like like
point by point laying out exactly what
happened even when he went back in the
90s and they he was just like i just
wanted to visit my homeland and they
turned it into this propaganda campaign
saying that i you know was supported the
revolution and it was just it was really
uh eye-opening hearing talk about that
when we're living in 2022. there's a a
clip that the left likes to put around
uh push push out there where at the end
of the joe rogan podcast with twitter
the hot the mic stayed on so joe is like
all right everybody that was great and
he stands up and it shows the rogan
symbol and you can still hear everything
and vijayagaday of twitter says i want
to follow up on that antifa account and
i said it's bit.ly slash antifa tweet or
something like that
and then she says
you know what was this account or
whatever and i responded with i don't
want to give you information on
specifics that you can go and ban people
because i'm here
basically saying i don't think you
should be doing anything on my behest
they cut that part out and claim that
twitter colludes with the far right to
ban antifa and support fascists and
it is insane
how people fall for this and believe it
and it's it's maddening and it's sad
because there are people who will hear
that clip and be like wow it must be
true that's it that's the combat
mentality i was i was talking to um a
few uh good friends of the show
and they mentioned dave rubin
saying something stupid they were like
oh but dave man he said that thing and i
was like what did he say and they're
like he said something about i can't
remember exactly what the quote was and
then i said wow you actually were
talking to him and he said this to you
they were like no but we saw it on
twitter and i was like
was he quoting someone else and they're
like i don't know it was a short clip
some activist posted and i was like so
why do you believe it
so so dave rubin could have been
quoting someone else and someone took a
clip of this and claimed he said it why
would you believe that
it's crazy that even people who are
aware of the tactics of the machine
still fall for it too yeah i definitely
um train myself out of it with the nick
sandman thing when he got confronted
when he confronted back in front of him
i i initially got angry and i was about
to yell out that was the first time i
kind of stopped and thought about maybe
there's something more to this uh and
then but it was like it wasn't like one
day i just stopped freaking out about
information i had to learn i'm still to
this day stuff will appear and i'm like
false flag remember false flag remember
keep your mind open yeah again that's
why i have no social platform whatsoever
i say i just think
as far away from that as i can i mean
obviously it wasn't part of my
generation i have a cell phone so i was
30. because they weren't around right my
first one i had was in belarus and
interestingly enough because it's such a
small country it was awesome because
they could put cell towers around
everywhere and it was really good but so
i didn't grow up with it wasn't part of
it but i absolutely detest
the fact that
you can get so inundated and so caught
up in it
that it
it's not profitable i try to be
profitable you know with my time and my
energy yeah i'll have such a good i'll
be in such a great state of mind i'll be
thinking about good stuff and then i'll
sometimes i'll get on twitter and i'm
like what the this stuff is so negative
it's so niche it's usually about like
biden or like about politics and it's
just because i follow a lot of people
that come on the show and that's what we
talk about but it's like so niche it's
not like reality
as it is it's just a part of like the
game i gotta i gotta give you some
advice man triggering tim look look at
look at who i fought you couldn't go on
twitter and pull my account and look at
who i follow
and so there's a good amount of
activists there's pundits there's
left-wing and right-wing pundits
and mostly news organizations what's
happening to a lot of people is that
they'll go on twitter and they'll follow
300 far left activists so their whole
world view is filtered by the far left
or they'll go on and follow 300
right-wing pundits and their whole world
view is filtered through right-wing
pundits
i i i use my twitter mostly as a tool
i post nonsense i often just you know
post things that like you know trigger
people or whatever you know i tweeted
today um was it today that uh putin was
scared of trump yeah boy did the left go
nuts on that one and uh but mostly
who i'm following is like news sources
left and right some some are politically
active some aren't a lot of journalists
you'll you'll see in my following
account like some professors and some
journalists my world view is not crafted
by partisans it is it is i have i have a
a a balanced you know because i want to
see what the left is saying sure no for
what you do it makes total sense right
but what we're getting is
journalists only follow the left
conservatives follow both
so you'll tend to see conservatives
understand the left left doesn't
understand conservatives that's why the
democrats support trudeau
and independent voters republicans don't
probably because democrats don't watch
the news have no idea what he's done but
if you went to the average democrat
voter and said trudeau seized the bank
account of a single mother who works as
a waitress because when the when the
convoy was was first just driving on the
road she gave 50 bucks they'd be like
well that's crazy
but because they don't pay attention
they support
authoritarianism and therefore wouldn't
believe you right right they'd say so
this is what you know my friends are
telling me they're like
they say like good friends of mine from
that from back home they say when i try
telling my parents they say it's a
conspiracy theory
and then and they they're like you know
tim like you you've known him he used to
hang out here it's he's the one who's
talking about like ah he's wrong i watch
cnn thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time